behold my creation monster do my bidding
i do as you come in master okay
mom you cannot have a problem with this
i'm mother teresa
are you kidding me what i'm her back
when she was hot i will pay you ten
dollars to go put on more clothes but
it's the first time you ever heard that
one okay you know what let's ju here
here we go
let's just cover you up all right now i
just want to run through this really
quick with everybody um first it's trick
or treat and then phil come on if you
dare right and then dad does the thunder
and the lightning and the fog usher the
children in past alex in her cage i'm in
a cage yes you're in a house of horrors
being held against your will yeah i know
so why do we need the cage
and then gloria pops up as the evil
village bruja and she says welcome to
your nightmare
and then cam and hayley do their thing
kids get their candy they are ushered up
they think it's all over but it's not
because out on the porch the scarecrow
pops to life wow for one final
and that's mitchell you're the scarecrow
oh no no i was in a costume all day it
was awful it's nothing compared to when
i was you don't own bad halloweens don't
i
we get it cam hard day mitchell please
the costume's in the kitchen come on
all right clear
before you go i just want you to do the
wig i love you more
okay okay thanks you're my best friend
hey guys hey wow
god you guys look great thank you phil i
try my best you look very debt-like
gloria stop it i said i was sorry oh no
no jay for now on i only speak improper
american so i don't embarrass you
did she just get back from the dentist
she's mad at me because i told her
sometimes people can't understand her
make it right jay
we're all just hanging by a thread hey
dad oh you look great oh good okay
gloria's in position hi gloria here you
go right back here i don't know that i'm
i'm feeling up to this why cam why what
happened that is so awful you
simultaneously can't speak of it and yet
can't stop talking about it i can't it's
too emotional okay some other time i was
ten oh god dressed as quasimodo on a
front porch with my best friend timmy
regular a ghostbuster there was a bucket
of candy with a sign said take one one
timmy took the entire bucket and put it
in his bag timmy didn't play by the
rules it's what i liked and feared about
him
then the bag broke as a crowd of kids
rounded the corner saw the pile of candy
timmy said cam did it
oh good god you're glad you got that out
okay everybody our first victims this is
not a rehearsal you ready you ready yes
yes
come in
if you dare
dad huh oh let me see
thank you for joining us
on our no no first the thunder and the
lightning yeah right i got it
perfect thank you for joining us
on our special night
other children haven't fared so well
welcome to your nightmare
what the hell is that uh can we just get
our candy okay but beware of the fog for
you might not be able to see a head ah
boo
timmy started running i wanted to run
two but my hunch got stuck on a rose
bush and that's when i fell i fell hard
i can see his feet okay here here
children have some candy happy halloween
[Music]
okay that was bad that was a bad start
uh first of all dad thunder lightning
fall cue and we skipped alex all
together and
gloria
says when do you speak english oh so now
you have a a problem with the way i
speak like father like daughter in this
dog-eat-dog family
or treat okay places places
good mitchell scott
i love you so much
come in
if you dare
dad
what dad oh right right oh
phil is you no dad
thank you for joining us on our special
night other children haven't fared so
well
oh help me help me
welcome to your nightmare
now your treats are over here but with
all the fog you may not be able to see
a head and everyone was screaming that's
him getting quasimodo and then the
townspeople started chasing me and
that's when i wet my pants
i wet my pants i wet my pits
this place is weird let's go okay come
on oh god
oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
you